[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist
and today we're going to feature an
exclusive interview
with the one and only richard dawkins
richard dawkins has a new book called
books do furnish
a life which we'll spend a lot of time
talking about because it goes everywhere
and that's where we want to go richard
dawkins professionally
is an ethologist an evolutionary
biologist and author
popularizer of his field in science in
general in rational thinking
all around and so much of what he does
is what we celebrate here on star talk
so we've got him richard welcome back
to star talk this is not your first
rodeo with us it's such a pleasure neil
thank you very much
yeah i was looking at your book oh my
gosh
richard that dare i say dare i even
suggest
that if anyone read only one book of
yours
it should be this because this to me
reads like a cross-section
of everything you have cared about and
expressed
professionally and in the public with
regard to what your life has been about
is that a fair characterization
well it's very interesting i never
thought of that before neil thank you
um it does span much of my career
ever since i started reviewing books i
suppose and writing
forwards to books so yes it's a good
slice of my
increasingly alarmingly long career
alarmingly
and i you know so i i worried because
people who start sort of collecting
their life's works
it's almost like they're ready to die
and i don't want you dying anytime soon
so just
that that's why i was worried when uh oh
uh oh let me check his heart rate
well let me let me reassure you i've got
two books two other books coming out
um uh one in november and one not quite
sure when but anyway
the one in november uh i'm looking
forward to very much
it's called flights of fantasy and it's
about flight uh
and um so i i'm not checking out anytime
soon
okay stay alive at least until your last
book gets published
uh i'm also i i noted uh as
do many prolific authors in the first
section of the book called front matter
there's a list of all of your previous
books
and i went down the list and forgive me
richard i haven't read all
30 of them 15
no but i've read like three and a half
okay
and i got the list i've read the selfish
gene i've read the blind watchmaker
i've read the god delusion and i've read
parts of other books
and i can say that every one of your
books i've read each one of the books
of yours i've read is a jewel it's a
jewel of writing it's a jewel of science
communication
it's a jewel of intellect so i will
extrapolate
and declare that every one of these
books is a jewel
and it forms a crown of some kind some
kind of bejeweled crown
that is a gift to civilization of how
you think
and how you would welcome others to
think to make a better world
how kind what what can i say i mean
i'd love to think that okay so let's go
straight into some of these topics i
very much embraced your organization of
the book uh there's sections and each
section
sort of delves into a an
area of of
science as it relates and as it is
received
by the public and and i'm honored
actually to be mentioned in your first
section
um where you recount an interview that
we had
in my office at the hayden planetarium
we talked about science communication
and we were sort of
trading notes as how i remember it and
to see you know what succeeded what
didn't and
what i want for you if can you tell me
over your years what have you learned to
do
differently based on
either the try the trial and error of
your successes or failures or
did you find one recipe and you sort of
stuck with it all the way through
i'd be interested to know what you'd
what your answer to that question is
neil as well
i i don't have much of a recipe and if
anybody ever invites me
to give a talk on something like science
communication
i don't really know what to say i mean i
just do it
i suppose what one of the things that i
do is to
put myself in the position of the reader
i mean that's an obvious thing how could
anyone not do that and yet
many people don't actually um you have
to imagine yourself in the position of
the reader who would
or the listener who would wonder what's
he getting at there what's happening
there
i don't i don't get that point please
elaborate on that point
so i tend to imagine
an imaginary reader looking over my
shoulder and
it can be a particular person it could
be a person that
um oh perhaps wrote me a letter that day
and so i've got to him or her in my mind
and so i imagine
how would it be what would it be like
for her reading this
what would be like for him reading this
i don't know whether you do anything
like
that i do that yeah of course all the
time but i
add another aspect to it i think and
again with
varying success most people
don't read so for me
i always ask myself is there something i
can add to this
that will attract someone who doesn't
have walls of books
behind them you know in in their bedroom
or in their den
and so that involves some sensitivity to
just people in the street and so i'm
wondering
for you how what is the difference to
you between
the written word and the spoken word or
the written word and the conversation
you're having someone who's just curious
in the street
you can't just tell them read my 400
page book
does it that doesn't work um and and
actually you're reminding me neil of
of one of our first encounters when you
took me to task i think it might have
been in
san diego or maybe seattle or something
like that um
and you said that maybe you said
something like
it's got to be an act of seduction an
act of persuasion
um as opposed to here's my book take it
or leave it
and you've just as it were reiterated at
that point it's a very good point
um i certainly try to do that obviously
to try to do that when i'm talking face
to face with somebody i mean you
you read the body language you read the
facial language you you see is it going
in are they are they getting it are they
shaking their head with doubt
um are they looking in the sort of
blanking comprehension
um so that's easy when you're face to
face with somebody
when you're faced with a large audience
which is a mixed audience
you don't quite know you you can't tell
how people are reacting
and of course with a book it's even
worse because you can't even see
their eyes as they're reading um
i suppose i try to take account of all
those things when i'm writing
um but it's not easy well let me tell
you let me remind you what i
precisely what i took you to task about
and just to to sharpen that memory was
2006
it was a conference one one of the early
conferences that landed on youtube
and so it got a lot of awareness uh
received a lot of attention at the time
today it might get lost in sort of the
noise of what's been posted
but 2006 and they finally got all the
talks together by 2007
so it was early clickable internet
content
um and it had a mixture of scientists
and
a couple of theologians if i remember
correctly skeptics and it was just
it's called beyond belief you know what
where do we go
if belief is not going to be the
centerpiece here
all i told you at the table which was
the
very first day i had met you by the way
and i was very nervous because
you're one of you're one of my heroes of
i was nervous too
of science and communication and what i
what i i had seen you give a talk
at this very same conference damn this
guy
is sharp and the wit is just
barbed and it's like and he knows he's
right and he knows who he's talking to
is wrong
and it was just it was so precise and so
there was no
room to have a person
just say can you let me just
i don't know recover for a moment
and so i worried that your messaging
was missing people because of how
articulately
barbed it was that it might have
actually turned people off
and then i i said perhaps you can
go at this with a
with a more of a subtle art of
persuasion
rather than just saying i'm i'm
paraphrasing here you're all idiots read
my book you'll be fine for it
see so that was that's what i came at
you for it and
it's all coming back to me very vividly
now
and i was i was very um i was moved by
it actually
and what i said at the time i think was
i gratefully accept the rebuke
and and i did yes you did
you were very gracious about it and by
the way no one back then knew
me from adam but they all knew you and
when i said this
it was basically an attack and there was
this
eerie silence in the room after i had
spoken
and and when you said i gratefully
accept your rebuke
it was like oh
it got a great laugh not least from you
i mean i i i recall i can actually hear
it again
your wonderful laugh as i said that um
and i hope i've learned from that i
don't know whether i have
i wonder whether you agree with me that
sometimes
if you make a great effort to be clear
as we both do it can come across as
a bit aggressive sometimes people like
to hear
a bit of flanneling around a bit of a
bit of woolly talk
and if you if you make a real effort to
talk
clearly they think it's
somehow two in your face
yeah so that's there is what you think
it is and there's how it's received
right and as
you can be an educator who
faces the chalkboard and puts the notes
on the board and not really paying
attention or you can
try to meet the people not just halfway
but maybe 90
of the way to their own space of
thinking
and yeah by the way this i
will talk more about this a little later
but my
primary the primary value of social
media to me
apart from what it is to wade through
the cesspool
that it is is i get to see
how people are thinking based on what
words i chose what phrase i composed
what
idea i put on the page and i can say oh
you're all wrong or you misinterpreted
me no
this is a real this is a real experiment
in progress if they misinterpreted you
if they didn't understand the word how
you used it if
if that happened that actually happened
it is
real so so i've used social media as my
source of awareness
of how people think what they think and
what i might want to do if i want to be
more effective
that's interesting and i i find your
your tweets which i look at from time to
time
uh very interesting because you tend to
be
i think you think of yourself as an
educator which you are and
and you tend to um give little snippets
of
in interesting fascinating science in a
witty kind of way
and uh so your arrest it seems to me
that what you're doing is arousing
people's excitement for science
by what you tweet and i wouldn't i
hadn't realized that you were actually
looking out for
how people respond to that that's
interesting yeah that's my
that's my so in a way it think of it as
a sort of a neurosynaptic
snapshot of how people are thinking
about what you're saying so that next
time you're in front of a large audience
in an auditorium let's say you now have
a
portfolio of the at least a statistical
portfolio
of how people are thinking and what
they're thinking and why and what
they're
um and how they're reacting more
importantly so that's that's kind of how
i
how i think about it there are people in
the world
very strong belief systems
and for many it's unresponsive
to evidence so there's that saying
i think it's 85 true you can't use
reason
to argue someone out of a point that
they didn't use reason to get into
so you need some other tactic uh you've
written so much
and spoken so much about religion in the
world
which almost by definition is is is
faith-based rather than evidence-based
and so how do you
what what are your tactics there
and and why do you even care if if we
live in a
free society people ought to be able to
think what they want
like why do you care what you know if
god
created the universe in six days and
this is deeply held by someone's
feelings
why does it matter to you don't you care
i mean
okay not so thanks okay okay all right
you just hit my serve back to me on a
tennis court
okay so i care when
the the religious thinking
of and there's so many religious in the
world and gods that have been praised in
the world
i care when that attempts to influence
law policy and the science classroom
otherwise if you go to
mosque on the you know on the weekend
synagogue
church i i don't
i don't concern myself with that okay i
think this is where we may slightly
differ
um i do care about that but um
i also care about this
but i care more than we live in a free
society where people can do that
yes okay i i obviously i'm more for
freedom however
um i do care if people think they live
in a very different kind of universe
from the one that
i think they live in um now you and i
would agree
that the universe um came about with the
big bang
um nearly 14 billion years ago and all
that stuff and
wonderful a wonderful story of inflation
and then
the origin of life and evolution and so
on this is a thoroughly exciting
exhilarating stimulating
story now if people believe
that the universe was invented by
a kind of superhuman being
that is a not it's not just a falsehood
it's a it's a
it's a denigration of the wonder of the
truth
and nobody's better than you at
expressing the wonder of the truth and
i'm surprised you're not
worried that there are people who
perpetrate promulgate um
this minimization of
the of the excitement of what's really
true well
you can offer them the truth but if they
prefer
their personal truths of their holy
books
then that's a decision they made in a
free society
now now here's the key words you use
promulgate yeah if they say
i am christian i'm gonna well this
happened historically it happens less so
today
i'm christian i'm gonna make you
christian at the
point of a sword then yeah i i
object to that right i don't i don't
want
people's the coercion of people's belief
systems being forced on
as an act of force on others being in
the school system or
or anywhere else but i walk in this i
live in a city as
as do you you walk down the street you
see people saying oh the
jesus is coming the end is near or
they're talking out loud to no one
and they're it's about um spouting
um bible verses and i think to myself
wow they really believe this this is
their
and that's their world and i i don't try
to stop
i have maybe because i don't have the
energy to do so
i don't i can't explain it i don't know
but i'm sure it's not that
i don't want them running for office
making laws that then have to apply to
other people
who have different religions yeah or no
religious course
no we we agree about that and i too do
not want to bludgeon people
into into uh believing what i believe i
want to persuade them i want to show
them as you do
how wonderful the scientific worldview
is i'm just sad
if they don't get it i mean i i it's i
of course they're free not and i
wouldn't i wouldn't want to compel
anybody
but they're missing so much and and you
must agree with that i mean
when you think of how wonderful the
stories that you tell in the planetarium
are
um if they don't get it then they're
missing so much and it's such a shame
that's that would be my way of looking
at it
so why is it their problem and not
your problem so in other words why isn't
while they're not getting it i must be
failing at my
attempts to operate them rather than on
their idiots thinking no no
of course i mean and that's why i work
so hard at it i mean i
i work so hard at writing these books
because i want people to get it
but i don't want to force them to get it
i want them i want them to get it
because it's so wonderful
is is it true that of all of your books
the biggest selling among them
is the god delusion um
it just is i i would like it to be one
of the science books but but
it it is yes because people are
interested in the subject of god
and i guess yeah and not only that your
i heard you say on i think it was an
interview that some
non-zero fraction of the sales of that
book
were from evangelical religious folks to
try to
sort of clue themselves in on how the
other side thinks do you have any
data on that i'm not sure about that
it's certainly true that there are about
um
22 i think books from evangelical
or from christians anyway replying with
names like deluded by dawkins and the
dawkins delusion and
permutations on the title of the god
delusion so that is true but i
don't have any actual statistics on it
that that's pretty cool deluded by
dawkins
okay so that meant somebody out there
was reading your book
that from the from the other camp yes i
guess
tell me more about your um
the goal of the the richard dawkins
foundation
and i'm delighted to say you you didn't
you don't have to say this that
your books are successful enough and
there's a there's a supply of cash
you can create a foundation that can
help causes
around the world in the service of a
mission
statement and and then the foundation
attracts donors who are of like mind as
any foundation
would be so could you just
give me a few sentences about this
foundation i i started it
uh soon after the god delusion was
published and i started it both in
britain
and america the richard dawkins
foundation for reason and science
it's now mostly based in america
and in the last few years it
merged with the center for inquiry cfi
which is a much larger organization and
so um
there's now a a big um
organization behind it um between these
these two it's a sort of sub
sub department of the center for inquiry
center right the cfi has magazines and
and there's a whole machine in place
yeah the whole machine there
and and and a big office and um
it has a whole division which is
concerned with non-religious nonsense
like um astrology and and homeopathy
and and things like that um being an
abduction by flying sources and stuff
and that's been going for a very long
time
um and also also has the secular
humanism going on
for a long time and so the richard
dawkins foundation
fits in nicely with that but it's become
a
sort of junior partner to the cfi
just a quick question about the term
secular humanism
aren't there deeply religious people who
would call themselves secular humanists
and if so you explain that to me
yes um there are and and there are
they they believe in well certainly
secular which which of course means
means just simply that you don't let
your religion interfere
with with politics you you so that
um uh so this is a separation of church
and state
so that in that sense the foundation of
the unit of the united states
is secular the foundation of india is
historically
secular um
secular does sometimes mean to some
people a more positive more negative
shall i say
anti-religious stance it's never meant
that to me but i think it does mean that
too
to some people um
humanism tends to be a bit like a
religion but it's not a religion because
it's godless
um and it's an ethical system
so secular secular humanism would be an
ethical system which is god-free
godless i got it so if you're purely
secular
then there's no way for you to think
about morality and other topics that
have been historically
in the domain of religions so humanism
is an attempt to
wrestle from i'm asking if you would
agree with
it's an attempt to wrestle from
religious communities
the the understandings and and
implementations of of moral code would
you say that
yes religious should not have a monopoly
on
on moral codes and on on ethics so
secular moral philosophy is important
subject for example so this is how you
can get religious people embracing
secular humanism
because or at least certainly secularism
but they they're perfectly happy with
their religion but they too don't want
religion
in the politics i guess there are people
like that certainly
and um in in britain for example the
um the um they call humanist uk now
what used to be the rich human
association um
they have a rabbi who is in charge or
was in charge of what trump still is
of the campaign against faith schools
against schools which indoctrinate
so yes there are people like that there
are many people who
um are sort of call themselves secular
humanists and who say that they're
religious but who often are
kind of spiritual rather than believing
in some particular religion like
christianity or
islam so
how then would you create
a code of ethics based
purely on sort of science and rational
thought
uh because i've heard it's passionate
um religious folks who can't
possibly embrace the notion
that moral code is invented by humans
that it's
they're sure it's something writ in our
hearts and in our souls by a divine
all-knowing all
all good entity well before answering
your question positively i should say
that the idea
that people who get their morals from
religion is a horrible one and you think
about where it would come from if you
think about
if you have ever read the old testament
for example i mean you would not get
your morals from the old testament
it's quite a bloody place yeah yeah nor
would you get your morals from
being scared of god which is the other
thing and that you know
by the way i have a quick story from the
old testament
and yeah it disturbed me actually uh so
we all have seen the cinematic epic
the ten commandments we've all seen that
with charlton heston
and we all remember uh mos
charlton heston as moses he comes down
from the mountain
with his with the tablets um
sorry i i remember the mel brooks
version of that where he has
15 commandments there are three tablets
and moses
accidentally one accidentally the lord
jehovah gives us 15
and then one breaks ten ten commandments
one way the other five i want to know
but moses did drop them break them
yeah he did right but after they were
already sort of released into the world
so uh yeah he dropped them on purpose
not by accident
so he comes down the mountain and of
course they're
they're the the tribes that you know
they made a golden calf and everyone in
this revelry and there's bonfires and
you know what is he raises his staff he
drops the thing and then
there's lightning and thunder and the
earth opens up
and all the bad people fall in the earth
and the good remain
and i said wow that okay sure that could
happen i mean if you're god and you're
connected to god
that's how that would happen then i read
what
quote actually happened yeah in in
exodus
okay i read this and it's oh my gosh
what does moses do he says are you with
me are you against me
step on my side if you're with me and
then took his sword
and massacred with he and aaron and
others
took their sword and hacked to death
everybody else
and i said oh my gosh
this is you know that's that's not even
god right
i can handle it because god was doing
all kinds of powerful things
in the old testament and if you're going
to open up the earth sure
only the bad people fall in sure but
moses does it
at his own hand and i said this is sad
this is and so i couldn't i couldn't
reconcile the two
and so what that meant was hollywood
wasn't going to go there they were not
going to turn
moses into a murderer
they were not going to do this or
someone who just totally embraced
killing
and so they cleansed even the bible
itself and
here we are thinking that the movie is
some epic
um slightly fictionalized storytelling
of important books in the bible
and they just took out something that i
think
would have been a uh like a scene out of
the movie 300 whereas bloody
you know heads cut off disemboweled
people
and that was not shown that's all i'm
saying well i forget to it was said the
best
advertisement for atheism would be to
read the bible in
anybody who actually reads the bible
from cover to cover is going to end up
an atheist
so well apparently it doesn't work for
for
everyone so richard what is the future
of religion in society you know it's
been around for
10 000 years probably neanderthal had
some kind of religion so it goes back
even farther
so it seems to be a pretty fundamental
part of the wiring of the human brain
so who are you to say let's just unwire
this it's almost evolutionary
yeah i i think it is of course it's it's
not totally because lots and lots of
people are actually not religious
and the number who are not religious is
increasing statistics show that
uh i mean i think even in america which
is the most religious
country in the western world i think the
number of people who
no longer have allegiance to any
religion
is about 25 it's about a quarter it's it
compares with any particular religion
that number
in size yeah i say okay so that's
interesting but it could just settle
there
right and just stay well you could do
but but but whatever the trend is i'm
hoping it'll continue
except unless of course what's what it's
what is replacing religion
is something like
astrology um you know kind of
nonsense which is not based on god but
which nevertheless is
supernatural um and is
just as bad if not worse well richard i
remember a study but i haven't seen it
duplicated
uh this is back going back now i think
to the 1980s
where someone went across the country
with it with a
uh not a quiz a a survey and asked
um do you believe in god or are you do
you belong to a church this sort of
thing
and in that same set of questions were
questions like do you
follow astrology or crystal healing or
spirit energies this sort of thing
and so there was sort of the
pseudoscience
in mix among questions about religion
and what she found this this researcher
was that as you go across the country
you hit the bible belt for example
the religiosity was high and the
the pseudoscience was low and as you got
to the pacific northwest
and other sort of famously famous
centers of pseudoscience the
pseudoscience rose
and the religiosity dropped and if you
added those two fractions together
they were roughly constant across the
country
which strongly indicated that yeah if
you take away someone's religion
it's going to be replaced with something
else what do you think of that deeply
depressing that yes
i i didn't know that i did not know that
study but it does not surprise me
uh it discourages me i must confess
um it's as though there's a kind of
quotient of
of nonsense which needs to be filled and
if religion doesn't fill it
then then other sorts of nonsense do
um i don't see why we can't fight
against that
um it seems to me that that's pretty
much what cfi is doing both its wings
both the
both the anti-religion part and the anti
um what you call it um other kinds of
superstition
part um i don't see why we shouldn't win
that battle
and science of course is the way to win
it i mean science is the antidote to
both
yeah what is your what is are there
any evolutionary thinking about the
value of superstition
in the species
i read a study that ducks can be
superstitious is that correct
they did some study but i i i forgot how
what the study was but i read it's like
damn the the bird was superstitious
because there was something it did that
where it got the same result and then
they
changed it but it kept i think you're
thinking of pigeons pigeons
pigeons yes um it's a classic study by
skinner who is the inventor of the
skinner box
and you know in the skinner box what
happens is that the bird is
normally rewarded for pecking at a key
and gets food reward um but if you turn
the
mechanism off such that it's used to the
idea that it should be getting
a reward you give it rewards at random
regardless of what it does okay
and what happens is if you have if you
have half a dozen birds
all in separate boxes under this regime
where they get
food reward at random they don't know
why they're getting it
what happens is that each bird develops
a different
habit superstitious habit presumably
quote thinking
this is what gave it the reward so you
will have one bird that preens its left
wing
another bird that pecks its foot another
bird that looks over its left shoulder
another bird that walks his round and
round in circles
all these things skinner observed
and that is a beautiful analogy to
superstition where you you sacrifice a
goat
and lo and behold the rainy the rainy
season comes which is what what you want
for your crops
and you think ah it must have been you
because we sacrificed a goat
and from then on you don't dare not
sacrifice the goat
um for fear that next time the rains
won't come
and so it is a beautiful demonstration
of superstitious behavior
in pigeons by the way i didn't know
pigeons had shoulders
he said it looks over its left shoulder
yes
they sort of do don't they i guess so
they're they're vertebrates so they've
got some anatomical
correspondence okay so any insight into
why
that oh oh because we we
want to believe we're in control of
outcomes whether or not that's
a very complicated world where um
in order to survive we need to do some
kind of intuitive statistics
uh maybe bayesian statistics anyway some
kind of intuitive statistics
um and uh we're not ideal we're not
very well versed in statistics unless
we've learned it
at school or university and so we have
to
intuitively guess that something that we
did might have had some
beneficial effect or some some bad
effect
and and it's pardonable in a way that
that we should be bad statisticians
it's entirely understandable that that
natural selection would have built into
our nervous system
a tendency to try to be a good
statistician
that's fascinating so what you're saying
is we are trying to be logical and
rational
in this world and so that
maybe gave us the capacity to be
scientific at all
but when you don't have the methods and
tools of science
it is rife with ways that
this effort to be that fails that's kind
of what and
add to that add to that that the world
we live in
is capricious and complicated and so
the the weather is unpredictable
virtually unpredictable
um the sudden appearance of predators
the sudden
um appearance of a spring in the in the
ground
finding a river all these things are
unpredictable
and so um i mean they are statistically
predictable but
they're not absolutely predictable so we
have to do
statistics we have to think
probabilistically
and there's i suppose there's a
trade-off between
what statisticians call a type one error
and a type two error false positive and
false negative
if you make an error in the direction of
say thinking it's a lion when it isn't a
lion
then you waste in you and you run scared
from every little
little movement of the bushes then you
never get any eating done
on the other hand if you're um too blase
and you assume it's not a lion then you
get eaten
in some of the cases yes yes yes there's
a difficult balance between
between being too risk averse and the
opposite of being risk averse
and and um where the balance should be
struck is difficult
and so when you get it wrong um it comes
out as
superstition can you comment
on the ethics of science
and who should be tasked with
establishing any kind of ethical code
i mean there's some out there but it's i
don't know that it's in any it's not
some centralized document thou shalt not
or without shall and so can you just
reflect on that a bit
yes oh by the way in my field thankfully
i don't have to think about
the ethics of like studying black holes
or the
origin of the universe there's no it
doesn't touch
human life in the ways that anthropology
does that can influence
legislation about how people treat each
other
or any kind of research into
the genetics of what it is to be human
or or different kinds of human
so i i'm i'm my field is largely
untouched by that the biggest trouble i
ever got into was participating in the
demotion of pluto
okay i got raped over the coast that was
big trouble for me okay
i wasn't called in front of congress so
um the the closest we come to ethics
is uh nasa has something called the
planetary protection
um division so if we send a probe to a
moon or a planet that might have life or
might have ever had life on it
it goes through much higher uh levels of
disinfecting or sterilization because we
don't want
you know someone might have sneezed in
the lab and some
rhinovirus lands on mars and then in 10
years we discover the rhinovirus on mars
so we don't want to contaminate our own
research
but also if we have sample returns
coming back there are protocols around
how that gets handled
and that's been going on ever since the
astronauts came back from the moon
they were put in a little sort of
airstream um
uh vessel until they were sort of
investigated decontaminated and the like
so that's that's
the farthest we go but your field oh my
gosh
um you know you go some things like
what your brethren were saying
in the 19 uh in the 19th century
just about humans and about races and
about and
and how that worked its way into our
society and into our culture
and how um and right on through eugenics
and and the tuskegee experiment so
what do we do about science going
forward yes
well i suppose um we want to make a
distinction between technology and
science and and you're talking about
science not technology
in technology of course there are
ethical problems and in a way
your thing about disinfecting is more on
the
that on that end of it that also i
suppose also
um the economics of um
space exploration i mean inevitably
no such thing as a free lunch what's
spent on space exploration cannot be
spent on
other things on on human welfare and so
that there is a there's that angle to it
as well but
you're asking me about my own field of
biology where
we do have to face things like um
the status of humanity the status of
humanity versus other species for
example the kind of things that the
philosopher
peter singer has alerted us to um
cruelty to to um to uh
speaking what's what's the definition of
human
um when does a fetus become human
uh end of life you know um um
euthanasia all these all these problems
arise in in medicine abortion
um you mentioned race and and the
um controversies over over
um uh discrimination and
and and racial prejudice all these
things that they're terrible
um things that as you said in previous
centuries
um i think things are getting better you
have to say that
yes they are saying people don't want to
admit it and particularly if you're only
born in the present
you think of only bad things in the
moment but
i had full record of what was going on
from my parents and my grandparents
which i would spend the last 120 years i
would say
where uh whatever stories i had
they had far worse stories and so i
i i had good anchoring in terms of as we
say the arc
of progress in our civilization
so richard what happens
if we both fail at the central mission
statements that we've carried into our
professional lives
we're trying to infuse the world with a
bit of rational
thought decision making um
what what happens the obvious answer
which
people might expect us to give i suppose
would be
that um we would
handle the kovid pandemic even worse
than we did
if science had been ignored completely
um and so science is obviously important
for
everyday life all aspects of everyday
life not just pandemics but but
everything so there's there is that
so if if if if science communication
fails and people come to mistrust
science totally
then it would be a very bad thing but
for me
that is not the only thing for me and
i'm sure for you as well
people i said before people be missing
so much
i mean science both your science and
mine
are great aesthetic experiences
i mean it's like missing out on great
art or great music
if you if you can't appreciate the
universe in which you live
the life of which you are apart the
cells
of which you're made these are so
important and so beautiful so elegant
uh and wonderful that i think that for
me would be the
the worst aspect of if we fail uh
richard there's actually a theological
version of what you just said
and it was uttered by gir donor bruno
which got him burned at the stake
it was thinking that the stars in the
sky
themselves are other sons that could be
orbited
by planets this or
he imagined that
god was bigger than the god
as described in the bible and so one of
his famous statements is your god is too
small there's a bigger god out there
of the larger universe where there are
civilizations everywhere
uh from here to the edge of the street
and you you you must know the
the carl sagan quote he says something
very similar like
um they say no no no our god is a little
god and we want him to stay that way
that
they can't bear the the fact that
science is making things so much bigger
and their punier imaginations could ever
conceive
so so we're not the only ones who are
aware of this
i remember one of the microsoft
billionaires i think was charles simone
endowed a professorship i think it was
at oxford
for the public understanding of science
and wasn't that a chair that you
occupied for a while yes um i was the
first holder of the charles simony
professorship of public understanding i
can't overstate how important that is
because
here are universities which to some is
just an ivory tower with eggheads and
they just talk to themselves
and they'll do anything relevant
somebody comes along and says
bring some of that outside of your iv
covered gates
and share it with the public and i
wouldn't imagine a more fitting person
than you for that but since then
there's a there's now a professorship
for the public understanding
of mathematics or no no yes
and another one a professor for the
public understanding
of risk did you have you heard about
that one
tell me about that very good oh my gosh
yes
risk risk can you spend a moment just
reflecting on
how people think about and make
decisions
in their lives regarding risk it's a
fascinating subject i mean it's not i'm
not
very much of an authority on it but yes
i mean they're extraordinary things
people get
utterly obsessed with what actually
amounted to a tiny little risk and
ignore something
far greater you get very unpopular if
you point this out because it seems
callous i mean some of my friends have
got unpopular pointing out that
oh maybe i better not even say but
something like the death toll from 9 11
was was dwarfed by the death toll from
motor accidents that kind of thing um
right
you can't say that sort of thing people
object because they say you're being
callous to all the people who died in 9
11.
but the fact is that risk is very very
widely
misunderstood and
obviously you feel the same yeah i do
and you're absolutely right i think
risk management should we call it that
the management of people's thinking
about risk
needs to have a psychological component
all right so you can be coldly
mathematical and say
don't do this because it has a higher
risk than you doing that
and you can tell people this but it
doesn't
land the same way with them emotionally
so richard here's an example of this
sort of mismatched
risk taking that people are doing it's a
story it's surely apocryphal but
we can all picture it where there's a
child being brought to the mall
and the child is not strapped in the car
seat okay
and they're just sort of bouncing around
the back seat
and the parent takes them into the mall
and
says make sure you hold my hand i don't
want you
wandering away someone might steal you
okay
so here's someone who is very hell-bent
on not
losing her child in the mall to some
you know a criminal who steals and eats
children
but took no effort to strap them into
the car seat
and and you can just look at the
statistics of stolen children versus
children who died
in car accidents by being improperly
restrained
and that should have just that should
have just had a very different situation
unfortunately in each case the child did
not die in that example
but um that's you think it would be a
simple case but people don't do it
there's a psychological dimension to
this that really is well understandable
i can't top that i mean that's
that's a very a very very nice um
example
i suppose another one might be the very
tiny risk
from vaccination where
list are not covered necessarily but but
any any vaccination where
that there are figures published whereby
a very very small percentage of
vaccinations have
an adverse result and people are scared
of that
and they they don't titrate that against
the
hugely greater risk from the disease
that's being vaccinated against
uh could it be that we are all at some
level
still deeply religious in the following
way
if a doctor gives me injection an
injection and i die from it
the doctor killed me if nobody gives me
an injection
and then i catch a disease just out of
the air
then that is the natural course
yeah in order of the universe it's not
just the doctor who killed it it's your
decision
to give the child the vet you you made
the choice to ask the doctor to give the
child that vaccination
so you killed the child right that
and that's the asymmetry there but
perhaps is what you're suggesting
right exactly so i'm just wondering
whereas if it happened by natural causes
there is no one to blame
and you're not gonna blame yourself of
course but you can then sort of
credit god in god's infinite wisdom
and god works in mysterious ways you've
got an out
in that direction without carrying
uh anger and ire for the rest of your
life you don't have to mean god in the
literature it could be just act of god
in the insurance companies
just just simply at least it's not you
were not responsible for it
you were not responsible so that's
another psychological dimension if we're
gonna
of course responsible because you were
responsible because you had the option
of
giving the vaccination and refraining
from vaccinating actually is what killed
the child
so so yeah but no one thinks we're not
we don't think that exactly because it's
not you're being rational again richard
sorry
so what i did was um when we had kids i
i found some document published by the
government
that rate that ranked causes of death
at different ages it's a fascinating you
know when you're eight year old
what is the most likely way you will die
if you die at all and this
changes as you get older right and um
so what i did was as our kids went
through the ages we'd go around the
house
and adjust what they had access to
in response to the statistics on what
was killing children
at that age and this that was so that
we totally did not approach that
emotionally we did it
um completely rationally but what it
means is you're absolutely right
our brain is not wired for statistics
and i was
astonished to learn
when someone the first person
to take an average of numbers
okay that's like the simplest statistic
you could possibly construct
it was something like the late 1700s or
early eight
it was not it was not a thousand years
ago
it was not it was it's very late
mathematics
and so that had to mean that we're just
not
wired to think probabilistically at all
if we could think
statistically that would change so many
laws that are on the books
about what is controlling our behavior
and what isn't
that's what what i would think richard
it's been great talking to you again
um and you have other books coming out
in the future
and so i don't like reading books that
feel like this
they're your epitaph but in fact at the
end of your current book
you have a final entry that you want
read at your funeral and
no no
no that would mean this is your last
book and i won't accept that but
you do say very important deep things in
it things that have affected my life
i have communicated it to others and
could you just summarize it brief don't
read it because i want people to read it
when they have the chance
just tell me in a few sentences what the
gist of it is
i'm tempted to say over my dead body but
um okay um
it's really reflecting on how lucky we
are to be alive
and my particular way of putting that is
to is to point out that
the uh the number of different
combinations of dna that could have been
here in my place
is mega hyper astronomical
um and so we are incredibly lucky to be
here
uh we're incredibly lucky to be on
to to to come to life on the planet that
we have which is
which is well obviously it has to be
well suited to beat for our life or we
wouldn't be here but nevertheless
we we are very lucky to be around and we
should make the most of our life
we should uh uh not fear death
necessarily but but try to make the best
of our life as long as we have life
because it's the only life we get and we
are very very privileged and lucky
to have it at all
and to be alive means we die which means
we're the lucky ones because we even get
to die
we're the lucky ones we get to die most
people have never even got to be born
ladies and gentlemen that's richard
dawkins and his
latest book just published by bantam a
division of penguin random house
richard uh thanks for being on star talk
thank you very much it's been a real
pleasure neil thank you
this has been star talk
thanks for listening some of you are
even watching i've been your host
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always beating you
to keep looking up
[Music]
you